when it comes to Marvel movies there's a
tradition that happens after the credits
roll that can be almost as important as
everything that happens before
spider-man homecoming is no different as
one of its two post-credit scenes hinted
big things to come the other one not so
much but it's still worth watching let's
get into some of the spoilers and
explain the post-credit scenes in
spider-man homecoming meat mats Gargan
in the first and most significant
post-credit scene the audience catches
up with the defeated vulture Adrian
Toomes walking through the halls of
prison after his showdown with
spider-man there he's approached by a
scarred prisoner a criminal who was also
on the Staten Island Ferry as part of
the vultures botched weapons deal that
guy's mad Gargan and we get a good
glimpse of the scorpion tattoo on his
neck ladies and gentlemen this is the
scorpion
one of spider-man's oldest bad guys
honor among thieves Gargan asked tooms
about the rumor that he knows
spider-man's true identity but the
former vulture denies everything paying
Peter back for saving both his
daughter's life and his own meanwhile we
know gargons got revenge on his mind for
the damage he took during the ferry pipe
setting up the sinister six Gargan tells
tooms
that he's got lots of friends on the
outside looking to go after spider-man
which seems to be a big hint that
Spidey's bad guys will soon team up in
the comics they're known as the sinister
six a group of villains with a rotating
membership over the years with the
shocker still on the loose by the end of
homecoming it seems likely that we
already know at least two of the
potential members who will make up this
evil gang of jerks seeing the sinister
six in a Spidey sequel wouldn't be too
big of a surprise it's well known that
Sony intended to make a spin-off
sinister six movie following what they
hoped would be the success of the
amazing spider-man 2 when that film
underperformed plans for the movie were
shelved that's when Sony worked out a
deal with Marvel's produced the 2017
reboot now that Spidey's back in action
with Sony and Marvel hugging it out it
wouldn't be that shocking if the
pre-production work that was done on the
sinister six film came out of the drawer
oh that Captain America thing viewers
who stayed to the very end of the
credits were treated to one more scene
this one featuring Captain America
himself standing against the white
backdrop cap reminds the audience of the
virtue of patience which
nice way of making fun of the fans who
stayed in the theater after the
interminable of credits crawl the joke
harkens back to the king of all
post-credit scenes the one from Ferris
Bueller's Day Off you're still here it's
over go home
does it have any relevance to the
further Marvel mythos well no it might
be the most pointless post-credits scene
in MCU history considering that even
guardians of the galaxy's Howard the
Duck cameo technically featured the
reintroduction of the classic character
what do you let it leaky like that SWA
gross anyone else feel like these
post-credit scenes might be getting a
little overhyped at this point it's over
go home thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]